-People say, you know,
I kind of look like him,
but, you know, I...
-A little bit.
-A little bit?
-I can see it.
-You can see it?
-Yeah. Freckles.
-The freckles, the gap, yeah
-If you put the Yankee hat on.
-Put the hat on?
-What do you think?
-You kind of look like him
-Yeah?
-You -- Oh, that's crazy.
♪♪♪♪
-We decided to have
a little fun with him.
We put him behind
an NBC Sports desk
in Bryant Park
here in New York City.
We gave him a pair
of Clark Kent glasses,
and we asked him...
We had him ask Yankee fans
about Aaron Judge.
[ Laughter ]
So a lot of them had no idea
they were talking
to the actual Aaron Judge.
It was really fun.
Take a look at this.
-I'm Aaron Judge, outfielder
for the New York Yankees,
and I'm here in Bryant Par
to see what Yankee fans
think about Aaron Judge.
[ Clears throat ]
Lifelong Yankee fan.
Your name, again, was...
-Mike.
-Mike. Big money Mike.
Favorite player so far
this year -- who do you got?
-Probably Brett Gardner.
-Brett Gardner.
-Yeah.
-Gardy.
-Ellsbury. I like Ellsbury
-Ellsbury.
-Aaron Judge
is tremendous to watch.
-Yeah. So far, he's...
I think he has about
13 home runs.
-Yeah.
-What do you think
he'll finish with?
-40.
-40?
-Yeah. He can't keep up
this pace, I don't think.
I mean...
-I think he can, though.
I think --
-If he goes to 60, great.
-Yeah, 60. Why not 70?
-Oh, I think Judge
is going to be a star.
-He's a pretty big dude.
-Yeah.
-You know, how much
do you think he benches?
-Maybe 350, 400.
-400?
-Yeah.
-You're right.
-Who's your favorite playe
right now?
-Adam Judge.
-By far. He's a beast.
-A beast?
-Yeah, he's --
-A beast, man.
-He's amazing.
-So you think he's
the real deal, then.
He's only been up here for
about a month, month and a half.
-I mean, I hope so.
I don't want to jinx it.
-Got a picture right there
-Yeah, he's --
I think he's going to be
a superstar.
-People say, you know,
I kind of look like him,
but, you know, I...
-A little bit.
-A little bit?
-I can see it.
-You can see it?
-Yeah. Freckles.
-The freckles, the gap, yeah
-If you put the Yankee hat on.
-Put the hat on?
-What do you think?
-You kind of look like him
-Yeah?
-You -- Oh, that's crazy.
[ Laughter ]
-I didn't even notice.
That's insane.
Definitely with a uniform on
-Oh, man.
What do you think about a gu
like Aaron Judge?
What do you...
The real deal or what?
-He's -- Yeah. He's good.
He's had a...
The month of April was his
-He's on the cover of the next
"Sports Illustrated."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Pretty cool, huh?
[ Laughter ]
I had a feeling, man.
I had a feeling, man. Come on.
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Laughs ] Judge.
-How you doing?
-You're the man, bro.
I had a feeling, man. I knew it.
-Yeah, it always --
It gives it away.
-You're the future, man.
We love you here, man.
-What do you think
so far of the year?
-I think some of
the young players
that they have now
have gotten people, perhaps,
that weren't as excited abou
them before really into it
like Aaron Judge.
Love him. He's...
-Love him?
-...exciting.
-So if Aaron Judge were
sitting here right now,
what kind of advice
would you give him?
You know, young guy on
a young team in New York City,
what kind of advice
would you give him?
-I probably would just say
"Be yourself because it seem
to be working so far."
-Be myself.
You say you love him.
-I really do.
-People say we look alike,
but I...
-You know, honestly, I...
-You see it a little bit?
-I really do.
Well, maybe it's the glasses
and the haircut on you,
but he's got
the Yankee hat, so...
-I'm Aaron Judge by the way.
Yeah.
-Oh, my God!
Oh! Oh, my God!
Oh, my God!
My husband is never going to
believe this, never.
I think I'm going to cry.
-A little selfie.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
-We sent Robinson Canó
out to the streets of New York
to get booed by actual
Yankee fans,
but here is the catch --
The fans thought they were
just booing a cardboard cutout
of Robinson Canó.
They didn't realize
that the real Robinson Can
was standing
right behind it.
Their reactions
are pretty great.
Check it out.
-Hi. I'm Robinson Canó,
and I'm about
to get boo by some Yankees fan
-Are you a Yankee fan?
-Yes.
-Now, Robinson Canó
is coming back to Yankee Stadium
tomorrow night
for the first time
since becoming
a Seattle Mariner.
Are you going to boo him?
-Of course.
-All right.
Well, we have this picture
of him right behind you,
so whenever you're ready,
go ahead and boo
it as much as you want.
-Boo!
You know what?
You're no longer welcome here.
Bye.
-Try it again.
-You're no longer...
My dude.
-How you doing?
-Robinson Canó is coming bac
to Yankee Stadium
tomorrow night
for the first time
since becoming
a Seattle Mariner.
Are you going to boo him?
-I am going to boo the [bleep]
out of him.
-[ Chuckling ] All right.
Well, whenever you're ready,
go ahead and give him
your best boo.
-Boo!
You suck!
That was it.
-That was awesome.
Maybe try it again.
-Should I try it again?
[ Laughs ]
How you doing, Robbie?
Welcome back to New York.
Good to be back, right?
-Yes, sir, kind of.
-[ Laughing ] Sort of.
-Are you going to boo him?
-You know, he won a World Series
ring here,
but he did leave
for the money, so...
-Why don't you go ahead and give
him as many boos as you want
-Come on, Robinson.
I mean, how many World Serie
titles do the Mariners have?
Come on! Boo!
You're better than that!
You got a beard now.
You're better than that.
Boo!
Ooh.
How are you?
-Good. How you doing?
-Pleasure to meet you.
-Thanks for the boo, anyways
-Yeah, man.
Welcome back to New York.
-Thank you.
-Whenever you're ready,
go ahead and boo.
-Boo!
You should go home! Boo!
-Try booing him one more time.
-Oh.
-Sorry, man.
-Are you going to boo him?
-Yes, I am.
Boo!
-All right.
Well, we actually have thi
picture of him right behind you,
so whenever you're ready,
go ahead and boo him
as much as you want.
-Boo, Robinson!
You should have stayed here!
Winners is in New York,
not in Seattle!
-Try booing him one more time.
-Boo!
Stay in Seattle.
We don't need you in New York.
Hey! How are you?
-Good. How you doing?
-I'm good. How are you?
-I'm doing good.
-Go ahead and boo him
as much as you want.
-Boo! Boo!
Whoa!
-How you doing?
Thanks for the boo.
-No problem.
I won't boo you.
I won't actually boo you.
I'll be rooting for you to
I don't know,
play well but not win.
-[ Laughs ]
-Are you going to boo him.
-Absolutely.
-All right.
Well, whenever you're ready,
go ahead and boo him
for as long as you want.
-Right here?
-Yep.
-Boo!
Boo!
Boo! Come on, everybody.
-Actually, try one more.
-One more?
-Yeah.
-Oh, [bleep]
-How you doing?
-Oh!
Listen, about that, right,
here's what happened...
[ Laughter ]
That's weird.
Only in New York.
Only in New York, I swear.